nearly 200 000 people
in south korea's gyonggi province are
part of a radical experiment
they receive about 220 every three
months no questions asked
him
is a cash payout based on a concept
called universal basic income
where citizens regardless of employment
or income are indefinitely given a sum
of money to help reduce
inequality and poverty universal basic
income has different names and the idea
has been floated in other countries
the freedom dividend of 1 000 a month
for every american adult
starting at age 18. during the
coronavirus pandemic gyongi pay was
expanded to 13 million people in the
province including newborns
to help them ride out the economic
slowdown and there was one catch
people had to spend the money only in
their neighborhoods to help stimulate
the local economy
the popularity of the local program
during the pandemic has now drawn
attention at the national level
and there's another big reason south
korea is one of the most automated
countries in the world and about 15
percent of jobs in the country are
projected to be automated by 2024.
so some politicians especially in the
manufacturing hub of gyongi
want to give all citizens about 430
every month to help prepare for a future
with robots
so the success of south korea's
experiment could change how other
countries think about adopting their own
universal basic income programs
has been part of what universal basic
income watchers call one of the world's
largest experiments of the concept
it gives 24 year olds in gyeonggi
province 250 dollars
every quarter to help them get started
in life
this money has allowed myunga to quit
several part-time jobs and focus on
finishing her bachelor's degree
gyong comes in the form of a credit card
emiyonga has to spend each round of
money locally before the next payout
she can't buy things in the town next
door or at chains like mcdonald's
spending has a trickle-down effect on
businesses like this traditional market
hua is a fish seller and he says
gyangipe has helped bring in new
customers
he says march was a tough month as the
country was just emerging from the first
wave of the pandemic and fewer people
came to shop
and killed province disaster related
basic income
the next month young pay credit cards
were made available to 13 million people
regardless of age or income level it is
paid quickly
it's paid in local currency and the
program was complemented with additional
coronavirus stimulus payments
and it helps increase small business
revenue
businesses that accepted kiangipe saw
their sales increase by about 45 percent
each transaction is funneled back to
gyeonggi government headquarters
where officials sift through data to see
how every penny is spent
gyong governor ijenmyong says data
collection is critical to fine-tuning
the program
because how else would he know if the
money was actually lifting the local
economy
foreign this raises a privacy concern
especially if it's done by the
government
iana marinescu is a professor at the
university of pennsylvania and she
studies the economic impact of universal
basic income programs
if you're being tracked uh that means
that the government you know
potentially you know in a bad case
scenario might use that
to exercise political influence and so
there's all these different aspects how
you know other benefits might be taken
away from you you might be put under
pressure to do certain things
politically
the gyeonggi government said that it
asks permission to collect data when
people register for their credit cards
online
it also said it only analyzes aggregate
data and not individual data points
marinesku says telling people where they
can spend money sounds like an efficient
way to boost local consumption
but this policy has a loophole money is
fungible and that what they're able to
spend locally that means they're saving
on whatever other money they have and
that other money they can spend it on
non-local or non-eligible types of goods
and services
governor lee is using the success of
gyeonggi-pay as a pitch for the 2022
presidential election
and he's now leading in the polls he's
proposing to give about 430
every month to all south koreans to make
sure the country isn't caught off guard
by job losses to automation this plan is
personal because his province is a
manufacturing base for major south
korean companies like samsung and
hyundai
[Music]
trade
[Music]
there will be fewer and fewer jobs that
a robot cannot do better
universal basic income has also been
championed by tech entrepreneurs who
believe automation will replace workers
and unlike unemployment benefits that
run out over time
these payments would be a stable flow of
income
the governor's program would cost the
country roughly 260 billion dollars a
year
and he plans to partly fund it through
what he calls a robot tax
essentially a levy on factories that
have automated their production
some opponents who think a national
program is too expensive
say money should not be spent on people
who don't need any help
but governor lee says all tax-paying
citizens should be included
according to a june survey nearly 50 of
south koreans are in favor of a national
universal basic income program
and they will have a chance to send a
message to the government during the
next presidential election